bonjour à tous de suite de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
pour 2008 il reste 80 amendements à
examiner
hé les sénateurs reprennent à l'article
41 qui instaurent un malus de 160 euros
pour les véhicules les plus polluants
ceux qui émettent plus de 250 grammes de
co2 par kilomètre et cela dès 2009 voilà
pour l'essentiel je vous propose de
rejoindre tout de suite l'hémicycle du
sénat la séance est ouvert le
compte-rendu rhin lithiques de la
précédente séance a été distribué et il
n'ya pas d'observation le procès verbal
est adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
par lettre en date du 10 décembre 2008
monsieur le premier ministre a demandé
au président du sénat de lui faire
connaître conformément à l'article l
451-1-2 de commerce l'avis de la
commission compétente du sénat sur le
projet de nomination de monsieur bruno
lasserre aux fonctions de président de
l'autorité de la concurrence
ces demandes d'avis a été transmise à la
commission des affaires économiques à
des données de cette communication
l'ordre du jour après la chute d'un
discussion du projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2008
dans la discussion des articles nous en
sommes parvenus à l'article 41 sur
l'article 40 et ré je suis saisi d'une
demande de prise de parole de monsieur
bernard véra auquel je donne la parole
merci monsieur le président et ses
ministres mes chers collègues
l'article 41 du projet de loi instaure
un malus forfaitaire annuelle de 160
euros pour les véhicules particuliers
émettant plus de 250 grammes de dioxyde
de carbone par kilomètre la taxe
concerne les véhicules neufs et est
assise sur le nombre de grammes de
dioxyde de carbone
et son barème augmentera progressivement
jusqu'en 2012 adopté l'initiative du
gouvernement le dispositif de bonus
malus avait été présenté au cours des
débats comme neutre pour les finances
publiques
le versement du bonus de la prime à la
casse devant être financées au moyen des
recettes tirées du malus
or il semblerait que le gouvernement ait
mal évalué les conséquences financières
de la mesure au titre des modifications
du dispositif
notre rapporteur général préfère une
augmentation significative du malus à
l'achat de l'ordre de 1000 euros à
l'instauration d'un malus annuel
augmentation qui selon lui serait plus
simple à mettre en oeuvre
de plus vous soulignez à juste titre
monsieur le rapporteur général qu'une
telle augmentation ne viserait presque
exclusivement que des modèles
particulièrement onéreux et par voie de
conséquence ne pénaliserait pas les
contribuables au pouvoir d'achat moyens
et modestes
cependant le dispositif de l'article 41
appelle plusieurs remarques
il vise à financer des mesures prises en
faveur de l'environnement ainsi qu'à
compenser un manque à gagner pour les
finances de l'état
sur le premier point nous considérons
que le bilan environnemental de
l'institution de telles taxes sur les
véhicules les moins propres ne
remplacera jamais la mise en oeuvre
d'une politique forte du développement
des transports publics
or comme en témoigne encore une fois les
crédits de la mission transports cette
année le gouvernement ne se donne pas
les moyens de satisfaire aux objectifs
du grenelle sur le second point le bonus
et la prime à la casse reste des mesures
en faveur de ceux de nos concitoyens qui
ont les moyens de s'acheter un véhicule
neuf
or en ces temps de crise alors que le
gouvernement refuse systématiquement une
revalorisation des salaires des minima
sociaux et des retraites
bon nombre d'entre eux continuent de
rouler dans des véhicules anciens
pour toutes ces raisons vous comprendrez
que nous considérions que les mesures
prises restent en deçà tant sur le plan
social qu'environnemental des objectifs
affichés par le gouvernement
bien je vous remercie chaque collègue
nous allons là sur l'article 41 4 3
amendements un sous-amendement pas me
demande mort est présentée par monsieur
dominateur que je donne la parole merci
monsieur le président comme vient de le
dire monsieur bérard effectivement pour
le gouvernement il ya une nécessité
puisque d'un seul coup il y avait un
coût de l'aide un peu plus de 500
millions d'euros de l'autre côté 250
millions d'euros de recettes
d'où l'idée d'instaurer je dirais le
retour de la vignette en réalité à
l'occasion de ce bonus malus
alors c'est un peu la nostalgie mais
c'est exactement ce qu'il va se passer
or je comprends pas vraiment la
cohérence de ce système parce que je
sais bien que cette correspond à un type
de véhicule particulier dont on dit que
effectivement ça ne concerne assez peu
notre industrie nationale
pour autant c'est tout un secteur
automobile qui est touché ce sont des
réseaux commerciaux
ce sont des gamins de véhicules qui sont
particulièrement importantes ou
attractives sur un marché et
deuxièmement on nous dit pas quel sera
le coût pour l'administration de
l'instauration de ce système
pour ma part je préfère l'annualisation
si l'on doit faire un effort financier
parce que quel est le coût est ce que
l'on va rétablir un service spécifique
qu'elle va être les coûts finalement
pour l'administration on peut peut-être
même craindre qu'ils seront supérieurs à
l'ars est envisagée c'est pour cela que
c'est un moment monsieur président
propose de supprimer tout simplement
l'article 40 r je vous remercie chacun
règle
nous avons un amendement de monsieur le
rapporteur général
cet amendement vise surtout à une
simplification parce que nous avons
estimé que créer un nouvel impôt
déclaratif
une sorte de nouvelles vignettes c'était
peut-être prometteur mais un peu
complexe et donc il nous a semblé qu'il
suffirait de majorer le malus à l'achat
et de l'augmenter de 1000 euros
augmentation devant entrer en vigueur en
2010 voilà quel est le contenu de notre
proposition
je remercie monsieur le rapporteur
général madame briques
vous avez la parole pour présenter un
sous-amendement oui on se rend compte
que cet article pose problème notamment
au sein de la majorité
et ça s'est vu dès l'assemblée nationale
et le rapporteur général nous propose
aussi de modifier le système car
initialement l'article prévoyez la
perception d'une taxe additionnelle à la
taxe sur les conventions d'assurance
par conséquent les compagnies
d'assurance aurait eu la charge de la
gestion et de recouvrement de cette taxe
dont le produit est estimé à 2 millions
500 mille alors les députés ont choisi
un système qui prévoit un mécanisme
déclare actifs sur le modèle de celui
utilisé pour la perception de la tva et
j'ai vu dans la liasse que le
gouvernement présenté un amendement qui
viendra en discussion ensuite et pour
faire que ce soit directement
l'administration fiscale qui perçoivent
cette taxe en déclarations mais moi j'ai
fait un sous-amendement avec mes
collègues socialistes de la commission
des finances pour que
ou à l'amendement de notre rapporteur
général qui lui substitue un malus
annuel substitut non il y près un malus
annuel à l'achat oui pardon c'est le
contraire oui excusez moi c'est le matin
il faut il faut se remettre dans la
discussion
alors nous on a un problème avec la
disposition du rapporteur général
d'abord on trouve que le tarif est quand
même bah basé
à 1000 euros dans le dispositif du
rapporteur général ou chez nos collègues
députés à 60 euros par an il correspond
pas à l'objectif parce que si on veut
faire en sorte que de dissuader de
l'achat de tels véhicules compte tenu du
coût de ses véhicules
mille euros ça paraît quand même pas
très dissuasif
et puis il prévoit que la date d'entrée
en vigueur soit 2010 alors franchement
pourquoi 2010 il vaut mieux le faire en
2009 sinon c'est qu'on croit pas du tout
à la vertu de ce dispositif
donc le sous-amendement consiste à
modifier la date est de faire en sorte
que l'application soit 2009 donc tout de
suite je vous remercie madame monsieur
le ministre pour présenter l'amendement
165 sur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs d'amendements
qui est présenté par le gouvernement est
de nature je crois à concilier
l'ensemble des demandes qui ont été
motivées par les déposer des amendements
notamment celui de monsieur le
rapporteur général
vous savez que le gouvernement par cet
article propose d'instaurer un
complément du malus à l'acquisition d'un
véhicule un malus annuel égal à 160
euros pour les véhicules émettant plus
de 250 grammes de dioxyde de carbone par
kilomètre parcouru
bien sûr cette disposition s'inscrit
dans le prolongement du grenelle de
l'environnement
elle est parfaitement en phase avec la
volonté exprimée par le président de la
république de mettre en place une taxe
écologique annuelle sur les véhicules
neufs les plus polluants ce nouveau
manuce annuel vient compléter le malus à
l'acquisition appliquée depuis cette
année alors vous le savez l'amendement
adopté à l'assemblée nationale a retenu
un dispositif différent de celui proposé
par le gouvernement afin d'éviter une
charge importante pour les assureurs
mais pour autant cette solution présente
l'inconvénient de ne pas garantir un bon
recouvrement de l'impôt et de faire
peser une charge excessive sur les
intéressés et donc pour régler cette
difficulté
vernement propose un mode de gestion
simplifiée qui n'exige aucune
déclaration de la part des redevables
car ceux ci seront informés par les
services de la direction générale des
finances publiques du montant du malus a
payé ces services se chargeant également
du recouvrement du point de vue du
contrôle ce dispositif présente toutes
les garanties dès lors que l'information
relative à l'immatriculation des
véhicules taxable est bien maîtrisée
enfin le mécanisme proposé par le
gouvernement évite la première année
d'immatriculation tout cumul entre le
malus dues au titre de l'immatriculation
et le malus annuel
ainsi un véhicule taxable immatriculés
pour la première fois en 2009 ne
supportera le manu samuel qu'en 2010
je crois que cette solution est à la
fois simple permet un bon recouvrement
de l'impôt et devrait être de nature à
rallier nombre de ces naines de sénateur
à cette mesure pour mieux si monsieur le
ministre monsieur doit porter général
votre vie sur l'objection de la
commission comme on l'a compris et est
d'ordre technique et il semble que
l'amendement du gouvernement
sans être parfait bien entendu va dans
le sens de nos préoccupations
alors pour bien entamer la discussion ce
matin sur le président je pense que nous
pouvons renoncer à l'amendement de la
commission exprimé un avis défavorable à
l'égard de celui du groupe socialiste et
rejoindre le gouvernement et sur le
monde ment de monsieur 2010 en quelque
sorte satisfait par le vat de celui du
gouvernement et qu'il pourra le retirer
bien à vis du gouvernement sur
l'amendement de monsieur 2009 fille je
vais demander à monsieur dominati sylla
l'obligeance de bien vouloir retirer son
amendement
vous avez la parole vous le retirez bien
iv retirer
il ne reste plus donc que l'amendement
du gouvernement sur lequel je consulte
qui est pur il faut compter n'est pas
adoptée contre il est adopté
1la moment desservi
il serait lui les trousses
nous passons maintenant à deux sur
l'article 41 bis nous avons également un
amendement du rapporteur général qui
tente suppression de l'article cette
question déjà évoquée en loi de finances
a pu être un peu approfondis par le
secrétariat de la commission et nous ne
partageons pas la référence ou du moins
l'interprétation faite de l'article 5 de
la directive du 27 octobre 2003 et de
plus à ce sujet il faut se référer aux
explications données sur le contenu de
cette directive par la commission dans
une communication au conseil du 30 juin
2006 en vertu de cette disposition les
véhicules utilisés pour les transports
publics locaux de passagers y compris
les taxis les ambulances et véhicules
utilisés par les forces armées et par
l'administration publique je souligne ou
encore ceux utilisés pour le transport
de personnes handicapées ou pour la
collecte des déchets peuvent bénéficier
de niveaux de taxation inférieur mais
supérieur aux minimas traditionnellement
assurée par les états membres des
raisons de politiques spécifiques y
compris la politique sociale alors si je
comprends bien l'européen
ça veut dire qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
autorisation générale pour
l'administration publique mais seulement
pour certains usages dès lors
l'amendement proposé n'est pas utile
puisque l'article 15 un petit i de la
directive de 2003 permet d'exonérer
totalement le gaz naturel carburant
utilisé pour les transports de personnes
le ramassage des ordures ménagères
effectué au moyen de véhicules
fonctionnant au gaz naturel
attendez je vous dise que
la directive interprété en langage
européen permet de faire pour que nos
travaux soit aussi clair qu'il est
possible en pareille matière enfin la
france a choisi d'utiliser cette
dernière faculté en prévoyant une
exonération totale de ticgn pour le gaz
carburant y compris après le 1er janvier
et vous avez donc déjà satisfaction sur
ces points bref tout ce qui a été permis
par la contrainte européenne est déjà
fait et l'adoption de l'amendement
exposerait malheureusement la france à
une procédure en infraction dont le
résultat serait probablement défavorable
donc si la commission émettent un avis
défavorable ce n'est pas défavorable sur
le fond
bien entendu parce que tout le monde
éprouve les mêmes craintes que vous il
faut d'ailleurs saluer votre vigilance
mais dans le cadre tracé par le droit
communautaire
malheureusement ce n'est pas possible
donc probablement ce texte n'a t-il pas
été bien négociés en temps utile par nos
représentants mais il faut le prendre
comme il est je vous remercie monsieur
important général monsieur le ministre
votre avis s'il vous plaît bien monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mon avis rejoint en tous
points celui qui vient d'être exprimées
par le rapporteur général qui fait
preuve d'une parfaite connaissance
européenne ce qui prouve son attachement
à cette construction est donc comme l'a
rappelé le rapporteur général
votre amendement revient sur un débat
qui a été tranché déjà à deux reprises
en séance
ici au sénat lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de finances de 2009
et donc je ne puis que réitérer
l'analyse qui a été faite alors quand à
l'incompatibilité de votre proposition
avec le droit communautaire comme l'a
indiqué monsieur marini l'article 5
comme il l'a rappelé de la directive de
2003 prévoit une possibilité d'appliquer
un tarif réduit
uniquement pour les usages en tant que
carburant des produits énergétiques
il ne concerne donc pas les usages
combustible ou de chauffage et du reste
la commission européenne l'a confirmé
elle-même dans une communication au
conseil le 30 juin 2006 comme l'a relevé
le rapporteur général
je tiens à votre disposition le détail
de l'analyse de la commission européenne
qui est très claire dans ce domaine et
donc pour l'ensemble de ces raisons je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez retirer
votre amendement
à défaut j'émettrais un avis défavorable
mogambo fils vous avez la parole mais
j'ai bien entendu ce qu'on dit notre
rapporteur général et monsieur le
ministre
j'entends bien qu'il peut y avoir une
interprétation de l'article 5 en
fonction de cette commission mais je ne
connais pas là la négociation et le
contenu de cette négociation
mais je vous ai fait part d'une
possibilité d'interprétation quand même
de l'article 11 sur lequel j'aimerais
que vous vous penchiez dans la mesure où
j'ai fait allusion au chauffage des
bâtiments communaux
j'ai fait allusion à la restauration
scolaire
autant d'activités qui peuvent être
assurés par des entreprises qui elles
pourraient bénéficier de ce tarif
minimal qui est aujourd'hui en
fonctionnement ce qui veut donc dire que
une collectivité qui agit en régie
municipale sera moins bien traité qu'une
entreprise qui aura en gestion certains
de nos services publics
ça pose quand même un véritable problème
et j'aimerais quand même que vous soyez
attentifs à cet aspect de l'article 11
qui à mon avis peut véritablement être
interprétée donc c'est pourquoi je
maintiendrai commun mon amendement je
remercie madame quand je me vois la
maman sentant de ceux qui sont pour
qui est content il met pas adopter nous
passons l'article 41 terre nous avons un
amendement du monsieur le rapporteur
général vise à baisser de 7% à 3 % le
seuil de chiffre d'affaires que les
achats de combustibles et d'électricité
doivent dépasser pour que les
entreprises de valorisation de la
biomasse soit exonéré jeudi biomasse
vous réagissez favorablement tout de
suite voilà soit exonéré de taxe
intérieure de consommation sur les
nouilles lignite et coke
cet assouplissement est conforme au
minimum communautaire qui est
précisément de 3% et est de nature à
soutenir certaines entreprises fortement
consommatrices d'énergie tels que la
déshydratation de la luzerne ou la
papeterie je vous remercie monsieur
général à vis du gouvernement bien
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur marini rapporteur
général
votre amendement est intéressant il est
intéressant puisque comme vous le savez
la directive énergie prévoit une
exonération de la taxe intérieure de
consommation sur le charbon pour les
entreprises grandes consommatrices en
énergie après concertation avec les
professionnels concernés le pourcentage
de 7% du chiffre d'affaires a été
proposée et adoptée lors de la première
lecture à l'assemblée nationale de 2008
mais elle vous savez pertinemment et
c'est l'objet de votre amendement que la
directive énergie prévoit la possibilité
d'abaisser ce seuil à 3% et donc votre
proposition présente l'avantagé
d'élargir le nombre de professionnels
appelés à bénéficier de cette mesure
d'exonération de la taxe tout à l'heure
monsieur le rapporteur général nous
avons examiné un amendement qui dans sa
philosophie était parfaitement en
cohérence avec celui que vous proposez
et nous aviez aller il ya quelques
instants émis un avis défavorable à
cette proposition
je rappelle que le coût de cette mesure
est identique au coût de la diminution
de la cua zoll l'incitation à avoir une
consommation accrue de la cloison pour
les pour les véhicules autobus donc je
voudrais trouver la pertinence de la
cohérence entre votre position il ya
quelques instants et celle que vous
venez de rappeler bien que je trouve que
votre amendement à celui ci est
intéressant je m'en remettrai du reste à
la sagesse de la haute assemblée mais je
voulais signaler ce petit accroc à votre
cohérence intellectuelle aussi grande
aussi grande habitude aussi importante
ni les reconnu monsieur le rapporteur
général vous avez la parole
sans vouloir trop développé ces
décharges féministe précisément c'est en
faisant une économie sur la croisade que
nous avons dégagé la marge qui nous a
permis de présenter cet amendement vous
voyez voilà voilà
et en plus ici c'est des produits
d'avenir merci monsieur le rapporteur
général je mets donc voir le monde mon
numéro 19 quai pour qui est contre il
est adopté l'article 41 terre qui est
pour et qui est contre et adopté après
l'article en interne nous avons un
amendement présenté par monsieur 2 min
tit monsieur le président je me
permettrai de présenter même les deux
amendements défendus depuis je dirais
des années avec comme si ils ont
rectifié bis ce soir oui tout à fait
monsieur président depuis des années mon
collègue charles revêt défend le
développement dans notre pays de la
politique ambitieuse de substitution de
bio carburant à l'essence ou au gazole
en 2010 la production française
envisagées de biocarburants et de près
d'un million de tonnes d'éthanol pour
l'essence et de 3 millions de tonnes de
biogazole pour le gazole un programme
important de soutien aux usines de
biocarburants a été lancé par le
gouvernement
les incitations sont de deux ordres
d'une part une exonération de la taxe
intérieure sur les carburants
d'autre part une obligation d'incorporer
les biocarburants dans les carburants
vendus à la pompe sanctionner en cas de
manquement par une taxe générale sur les
activités polluantes
plusieurs projets de construction d'une
usine de bio d'asie de bio diesel en
france sont en cours et devraient voir
le jour en 2010 il sera produit un bios
déziel de deuxième génération qui
respectera le critère de non concurrence
avec l'alimentation humaine réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
utilisation la plus complète possible de
matières premières d'origine afin de ne
pas stopper ces projets l'amendement 145
prévoit le maintien de l'exonération de
la tic pour les usines de bio diesel de
deuxième génération
au delà de 2012 ce qui devrait coûter
environ 30 millions d'euros à l'état
contre 1 milliard actuellement pour les
usines de première génération
l'amendement 146 vise à se conformer dès
maintenant à l'article 18 paragraphe 4
du projet de directive européenne sur la
promotion des énergies
renouvelables en date du 23 janvier 2008
qui prévoit que la contribution des
biocarburants de deuxième génération
sera considérée comme double de celle
des autres biocarburants en matière de
respect des obligations des opérateurs
au titre des énergies renouvelables je
vous remercie monsieur de minetti avant
de demander l'avis du rapporteur général
je voudrais revenir sur l'amendement
numéro 19 pour demander au gouvernement
s'il lève le gage je ride le demander
oui oui vous remercie bien monsieur le
rapporteur général votre avis sur les
deux amendements présentés par monsieur
dominati président ce sont de bons
amendements car il est important
d'encourager les biocarburants de
seconde génération
ces derniers n'entre pas en concurrence
avec l'alimentation humaine sont moins
polluants que les biocarburants de
première génération et la recherche se
poursuit pour les mettre au point
ceci étant dit leur degré de
développement est encore faible et
encore beaucoup de travail de recherche
et je me demande si les mesures
proposées par les deux amendements ne
sont pas quelque peu prématurée donc si
nous sollicitons l'avis du gouvernement
si nous serons probablement amené à
solliciter le retrait des amendements
cela ne veut pas dire que sur le fond la
commission soit défavorable mais
simplement nous pensons que l'état des
technologies ne justifie pas encore de
telles mesures et que bien entendu le
jour venu il faudrait être en mesure
d'en fait il faudrait être capable de
bien définir leur coûte et que ce coûte
s'insère dans un plan cohérent vis-à-vis
de l'ensemble des biocarburants c'est à
dire que si on donne plus d'un côté il
faudra donner moins de l'autre me
semble-t-il
mais si monsieur le ministre votre avis
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mon avis
il est directement tiré d'une certaine
manière de l'analyse que vient de faire
philippe marini
il faut se garder d' insulte et le futur
et dans ce cadre faire parler d'eux
amendement une défiscalisation
supplémentaire pour certains ester
méthylique outre le coût de la mesure
outre le débat très large qui a eu lieu
sur le bon niveau de défiscalisation des
biocarburants à l'occasion du projet de
loi de finances de 2009
me semble important suffisant pour que
le gouvernement émettent un avis
défavorable à ces deux amendements
je le répète je pense que il y a eu ce
débat il a été très large 13 ample n'a
pas épuisé le sujet mais coût de la
mesure de proposer par l'amendement 145
rectificative bis c'est un peu plus de
80 millions d'euros sur 2009-2011 c'est
dire l'importance et enfin nous aurions
à nous interroger sur le fait de savoir
si cette classe de biocarburants
appartient à la catégorie seconde
génération la directive sur les énergies
renouvelables ne semble pas
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
ce qui est affirmé par charles revêt
classer ces biocarburants dans la
catégorie des seconde génération donc je
prends il faut donner un peu de temps
avant de se prononcer sur des mesures
aussi aussi fortes que celles qui sont
proposées dans le cadre de ces deux
amendements pour ces raisons que le
gouvernement a émis un avis défavorable
sur les deux je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre pour explication de vote
monsieur jean bizet merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
je suis absolument désolé d'être en
porte à faux avec monsieur le ministre
et avec le rapporteur général
c'est vrai que c'est un peu prématuré
mais les choses vont très vite et moi je
crois véritablement qu'il ne faut pas
que nous prenions de retard sur ce sujet
par rapport à d'autres pays
et croyez moi il est moins prématurée
qu'il n'y paraît je pense que
véritablement qu'il faut donner un signe
d'encouragement ces biocarburants de
deuxième et de troisième génération à
mon avis je crois qu'il ne faut pas
retiré ses amendements
joe merci chers collègues eh bien je
vais mettre voir monsieur nominative
obligataire 145 rectifié bis quai pour
qui est contre
il faut il va falloir procéder par la
siedo pardon oui je suis le secrétaire
venez s'il vous plaît officiers vous
vouliez aux fichiers de votre place
alors qui est constamment devez vous je
vous prie c'est vous qui qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté nous pressons 146
rectifié bis quai pour que pour même
vote
il n'est pas adopté nous passons à
l'amendement présenté par messieurs sido
et pintât il tombe article terrain de
jeu 90 2 prises de paroles de monsieur
bernard véra vous avez la parole chaque
collègue
merci monsieur le président ce ministre
mes chers collègues cet article 42
inaugure une série de dispositions
diverses dans ce collectif regroupés
dans un chapitre intitulé mesures
sectorielles
cette définition recouvre des réalités
extrêmement diverse et affecte le
secteur agricole mais aussi la situation
de taxe professionnelle de quelques
assujettis ou encore le mode de
traitement des établissements bancaires
mutualistes au titre de l'impôt sur les
sociétés sur ces articles dont la
pertinence et la portée semble
globalement limité nous sommes face à
une théorie de dispositions qui font un
peu voiture balai et qui consiste pour
l'essentiel après consultations
sectorielles validé en catastrophe dans
la loi de finances
le produit de la concertation aussi nous
ne pensons pas qu'il y a urgence à
légiférer comme un autre collectif
budgétaire s'annonce pour le mois de
janvier autant attendre cette date pour
mesurer tous les enjeux de ces
dispositions c'est pourquoi dans la
tente
nous ne voterons aucun des articles
contenus dans ce chapitre je remercie
chers collègues je sais saisie de trois
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
le premier amendement 57 rectifier et
présentée par monsieur césar
oui merci monsieur le président en effet
l'amendement 57 rectifier et dans
l'article 42 l'objectif est d'améliorer
le dispositif actuel de la déduction
pour aléas dpa je traduis parce qu'il ya
la nuit sur les cibles mais quelques
problèmes cet objectif doit être
approuvé dès lors que le dispositif
actuel très inadaptée n'a pratiquement
pas été utilisé depuis sa création par
la loi du 29 décembre 2000 heures
l'évolution de la dpa emporte les
colonnes des conséquences sur les
régimes de la déduction pour
investissement la dpi
or cette évolution ne doit pas être
conduites de façon pénaliser certains
secteurs ou certains entreprises
dispositif très appréciée utile à des
pays notation pour l'investissement
rencontre important saisissement
nécessaires à l'activité agricole est
spécialement viticole matériels
équipements et stocke réduire la des
pires vient alourdir la fiscalité qui
pèse une exploitation viticole ce qui
est évidemment mal venu dans une période
où convient plutôt de soutenir la
capacité d'investissement des
entreprises
les vignerons ont largement recours à
des pays afin de financer leurs stocks
c'est en effet le seul régime dispose
des pics dispositif de blocage des
stocks à rotation lente a été supprimé
au motif d'ailleurs qu'il vous est
double emploi avec des pays
tous les indicateurs montrent par
ailleurs un ralentissement des
transactions de 20 sur le marché
c'est là devant donc se répercuter
directement sur les stocks la production
les vignerons vont devoir faire face et
le conjoncture difficile avec une
augmentation de leurs stocks par
conséquent la diminution très importante
du bluff en dépit n'est pas acceptable
l'article 40 dieu issus de débarras
allen se propre restaurer un plafond
maximal d'un dpi à 18000 euros
par ailleurs la progressivité pour
athènes ce plafond était minoré pour les
entreprises quant au résultat de moins
de 30000 euros
l'amendement que je propose se propose
de porter le seuil de la dpi à 20000
euros et de revenir à la progressivité
actuelle afin de ne pas pénaliser les
petites entreprises
ce césar ce que vous êtes debout
j'en profite présenter le 48 fichiers
l'article 42 issus des balles à la haine
proposé sur un plafond maximum je viens
d'en parler de la dpi à 18000 euros
par ailleurs la proximité pour atteindre
ce plafond était minoré par les
entreprises que les résultats d'au moins
trente mille euros
donc cet amendement 48 rectifie est un
pas en contradiction avec le 57 et donc
si vous permettez monsieur le président
moi je propose de simplifier et de dire
qu'on ne retenant si l'amendement 57 et
adoptez donc le plafond de 20 mille
euros je vous remercie
chers collègues qui présente le 113 ou
groupe socialiste mais monsieur le
président moshé ministre l'amendement à
l'article 42 présenté par madame bonne
foi a pour but d'améliorer le dispositif
actuel de la déduction pour aléas
nous approuvons la démarche car le
dispositif actuel très inadaptée n'a
pratiquement pas été utilisé depuis sa
création par la loi du 29 décembre 2001
mais l'évolution de la déduction pour
aléas des conséquences sur le régime de
la déduction pour investissement
et cette évolution ne doit pas être
conduites de façon à pénaliser certains
secteurs ou certaines entreprises
dispositif très utile et apprécié la
déduction pour investissement prend en
compte l'importance des investissements
nécessaires à l'activité agricole est
spécialement viticole matériels
équipements et stocke réduire la
déduction pour investissement revient à
alourdir la fiscalité qui pèse sur les
exploitations viticoles
ce qui est évidemment mal venu dans une
période où il convient plutôt de
soutenir la capacité d'investissement
des entreprises
les vignerons ont largement recours à la
déduction pour investissement pour
financer leurs stocks
c'est en effet le seul régime dont ils
disposent depuis que le dispositif de
blocage des stocks à rotation lente a
été supprimé au motif d'ailleurs que ce
dispositif faisait double emploi avec la
déduction pour investissement
tous les indicateurs montrent par
ailleurs un ralentissement des
transactions de 20
sur les marchés cela va se répercuter
directement sur les stocks à la
production les vignerons vont donc
devoir faire face à une conjoncture
difficile avec pour conséquence une
augmentation de leurs stocks
par conséquent la diminution trop
importante du plafond de la déduction
pour investissement n'est pas
souhaitable et serait extrêmement
dommageable
l'article 42 issus les débats de
l'assemblée nationale se propose
d'instaurer un plafond maximal de la
déduction pour investissement à 18000
euros
par ailleurs la progressivité pour
atteindre ce plafond a été minoré pour
les entreprises qui ont un résultat de
moins de 30000 euros
l'amendement que nous présentons propose
donc de porter le seuil de la déduction
pour investissement à 20000 euros et de
revenir à la progressivité actuelle afin
de ne pas pénaliser les petites
entreprises
je vous remercie scheer que lègue à vis
de la commission devant ce consensus
viticole président la commission est
très attaché et la viticulture bien
entendu profession agricole en général
aux progrès de la fiscalité qui les
concernent
alors nous observons que l'amendement
157 et le 113 qui sont très proches qui
sont même identique et porte de 18000 à
20000 euros le plafond annuel de
déduction pour investissement et
assouplissent les règles de
progressivité de ce plafond en fonction
du bénéfice
ces assouplissements sont bienvenues
notamment pour les exploitations
viticoles qui font face
traditionnellement à de lourds
investissements et qui financent leurs
stocks au moyen de 7 des pays et le
retour à un barème progressif est
également favorable aux entreprises
petites et moyennes la commission est
donc d'avis monsieur le ministre
d'accepter cette excellente initiative
que nous ont exposés successivement
gérard césar puis nicole oui monsieur
yannick botrel et l'amendement de repli
numéro 48 tombe de roissy si les
précédents sont adoptés si monsieur
l'important général monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
le gouvernement suit la position de la
commission sur ces amendements de
soutien à un secteur qui est
particulièrement important
y compris chez moi et mais ça n'est pas
la raison de la position du gouvernement
bien sûr en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que les amendements que vient de
présenter
gérard césar c'est à dire les
amendements 57 rectifié 48 rectifié 50
de rectifier bis rencontre l'assentiment
et le soutien du gouvernement donc nous
émettons un avis favorable à l'ensemble
des amendements qui ont été présentés
par monsieur césar ainsi que amendement
113 de madame bonne foi jean pierre
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
césar n'a pas encore présenté le 5 en
demi c'est le 49 rectifié attendons vous
levez le gage
monsieur le ministre vous ne verrez bien
je consulte donc sur le 57 rectifier le
113 qui sont identiques qui est pour et
qui est contre
je vous prie de m'excuser monsieur
gaillard
je vous en prie je vous donne la parole
parce que nous écoutons toujours avec
beaucoup d'attention et de plaisir
non je voulais simplement dire que ce
vote est un amendement va
qu'enthousiaste parce que de tous les
vignerons les vignerons de champagne
sont ceux qui sont parmi les plus
intéressés à cet amendement
et je regrette de regrets de choquer le
sens moralisateur de monsieur verra qui
n'aiment pas les abonnements sectorielle
bien je vous remercie donc le cas
ensuite rectifié tombe et nous passons
maintenant aux cinq ans de rectifier bij
ville présenter monsieur césar
oui merci monsieur le président en effet
les 52 bis propose d'ajouter au
dispositif dotation pour aléas
une mesure qui prend en compte le nombre
de salariés sous la forme de complément
de réduction cette mesure existe déjà
dans le dispositif actuel
il paraît donc logique de la reconduire
dès lors que s'inscrit dans la politique
d'encouragement à l'emploi voulu par le
gouvernement
monsieur césar monsieur le rapporteur
général s'il vous plaît votre a proposé
par le gouvernement portent déjà le
plafond spécifique de la déduction pour
aléas 23000 euros la somme des plafonds
de dpa et de des pays atteindrait 38000
euros contre 26 milles sous le régime
actuel et ceci étant dit nous avons bien
vu que votre amendement supprime la
pousse que vous faites que votre
amendement réintroduit la possibilité
pour les exploitants de pratiquer un
complément de dotation de 5000 euros par
salarié de tenues de 500 euros par vol
oui pardonnez-moi 500 euros
effectivement de déduction pour aléas
par salariés équivalent temps plein
lorsque le résultat de l'exercice est
supérieur de 20% la moyenne des trois
exercices précédents
bon sur ce point la commission s'en
remet à l'avis du gouvernement merci à
vos râble le gouvernement est favorable
le vais vous le gage
oui très bien pas d'explications de vote
je mets ce voile 50 de rectifier bis
quai pour qui est contre et adoptez vous
avez un autre amendement monsieur césar
la présidence tout votre activité
mercière sur le 49e rectifier il s'agit
donc des conditions de l'intégration de
la déduction pour aléas
car le projet actuel vizelia d'origine
et climatiques naturelles ou sanitaires
et nous avons connu des crises
sanitaires très importante il ya peu de
temps malheureusement et le contexte
actuel des mondes que la liga économique
constitue une menace au moins aussi
importantes pour l'entreprise que les
seuls risques d'origine climatique
naturelle et sanitaires
c'est pourquoi le présent amendement
propose d'intégrer la notion d' aléas
économiques et surtout dans la tente de
réforme de l'assurance récolte que
l'union européenne a promis donc au
niveau des 27 pays
c'est important de pouvoir le préciser
le gouvernement justifie cette réforme
le dpa par le costa de la nombre
activités actuelles ce dispositif est le
souhait de lui donner une véritable
ampleur
il apparaît dès lors totalement
contradictoire de vouloir restreindre
son champ d'application
l'article 40 devises comme révélateur
d'un est liée à la variation du chiffre
d'affaires ont ce dernier intègre les
volumes commercialisés et les prix mais
ne tient pas compte des charges
supportées par les spots ans ce qui fait
des résultats
un indice de quantification de
l'activité économique d'entreprises plus
pertinents je remercie vous remercie
cher que les monsieur le rapporteur
général votre avis s'il vous plaît le
chiffre d'affaires est une donnée
économique objective alors que le
résultat d'une exploitation est par
définition volatile et le retour est une
référence aux résultats pour effet
de la dpa pourrait faire dans certains
cas un instrument de lissage du revenu
des exploiteurs n'est sans doute pas sa
vocation
par ailleurs l'exclusion de l'aléa
économique est motivée par la très forte
corrélation voulu entre dpa et
souscription d'une assurance contre les
risques climatiques et sanitaires
cette incitation à l'assurance serait
affaiblie si la dpa pouvait être utilisé
en cas d'aléas économique alors pour ces
raisons là vous le voyez la commission
n'est pas présente aux yast et
souhaiterait le retrait de l'amendement
monsieur le ministre il ya monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gérard
césar ham malgré sympathie et désir de
vous être agréable et le fondement des
les amendements précédent pour
lesquelles le gouvernement a émis un
avis favorable qui semble tout à fait
fondée par contre je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur sur le fait que cet
amendement revient ou dénature la
réforme du gouvernement souhaitait par
le président de la république pourquoi
cela parce que la réforme de la de la
dpa ne prévoit pas le maintien en l'état
du régime actuel de la dpa
parce que ce régime ne fonctionne pas
c'est même la raison fondamentale de
cette réforme
seules 200 agriculteurs sur 44 mille
utilisent cette dpa d'eau qu'il y avait
urgence à faire en sorte que celle ci
puisse fonctionner dans un autre cadre
et son recentrage dans le cadre d'une
vraie politique assurantielle de
couverture des risques climatiques et
sanitaires apparaît tout à fait fondé la
durée c'est est annoncé je le disais à
l'instant par le président l'aléa
économique que vous proposez au sens où
vous l'entendez n'est en réalité qu'un
moyen de transformation profonde de
cette dpa une nouvelle dpa
une sorte de dpi bis qui s'apparenterait
à un simple mécanisme de lissage des
revenus et
on a en a on arrive à un objectif
complètement étranger à la démarche qui
sous tend notre réforme la réforme du
gouvernement
or si nous allions dans votre sens cet
aléas économiques que vous évoquez n'a
rien de spécifique au monde agricole
l'aléa économique il existe pour tous
pour toutes les professions pour les
entreprises du secteur artisanal
industriel commercial libéral qui
connaissent elles aussi des cycles
d'activité et donc les mêmes difficultés
économiques liées notamment à
l'augmentation de leurs charges
donc je voulais vous dire que le
gouvernement et est fortement
défavorable à votre proposition qui
remettraient parfaitement est totalement
en cause la réforme c'est pour ça
monsieur le sénateur je souhaiterais que
vous puissiez retirer votre amendement
monsieur le sénateur ge le césar le
président je tapais j'ai bien entendu
les observations du rapporteur général
du budget dé monsieur le ministre c'est
vrai que je comprends la position mais
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs ont connu
comme nous l'avons vu des crises
sanitaires climatiques économiques mais
je crois que dans le cadre d'assurance
récolte que nous entrevoyons au niveau
européen on pourrait justement un palier
ce problème
donc moi je retire mon amendement mais
je rappelle que cette dpa envoyé pour
objectif aussi de pallier les aléas de
l'assurance et je rappelle aussi que
l'agriculteur ne peut pas bénéficier du
chômage technique comme d'autres
donc je le retire mais je crois que nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler dans les
prochains jours merci je remercie chers
collègues bien la maman et en retirer je
consulte sur l'arctique en deux quais
pour qui et contre 8 adoptée après
l'arctique en deux nous avons un
amendement présenté par monsieur
gaillard modem dumas monsieur gaillard
oui c'est un amendement qui encourage le
crédit les avances remboursables par
bénéficiaire est pas rentrer dans un
maximum de 5000 euros
en déduisant permettant aux banques de
ne pas de déduire les charges de
refinancement correspondant à ses
avances c'est une politique qui avait
annoncé le ministre de la culture de mme
albanel
il ya dans sa dernière où son avant
dernière conférence de presse et qui
s'inspire d'une politique qui a été
lancé en angleterre il ya déjà deux ou
trois ans et qui est très utile pour
permettre les achats d'oeuvres d'art
deux artistes ou de moins jeunes et que
la constitution de collections
personnelles vous savez que le marché de
l'art français n'est pas dans une très
bonne situation et tout ce qui peut
l'encourager
de façon assez peu coûteuse et
souhaitable je remercie le rapporteur
sur le président tu le ministre mes
chers collègues il avait été convenu
lors des débats à l'assemblée nationale
de retirer cet amendement qui ne peut
pas être adopté en l'état
pourquoi les problèmes sont nombreux
premièrement aucune conditions
d'exposition de l'oeuvre aucune
condition de nationalité de l'artiste
vivant concernés aucun engagement de
conservation de l'oeuvre aucune
limitation au nombre de près 0 qui
pourraient être consentis à la même
personne alors très sincèrement surtout
dans la période de crise que nous
connaissons se payer ainsi du superflu
sans limite et aux frais de l'état
sincèrement la commission ne peut pas
suivre dont il faudrait peut-être borne
est un peu mieux ce dispositif bon et
est bon le rapport de monsieur bethenod
remis à la demande de la ministre de la
culture il ya quelques mois d'un rapport
d'une imagination un remarquable parce
que ce rapport
ils apportaient des améliorations au
marché de l'art en ne prenant que des
mesures fiscales
c'était de la niche niche après niche
ligne par ligne
il y en avait 40
et alors là il y en a une qui ressurgit
dans un amendement l'assemblée nationale
voilà donc monsieur le ministre la vie
de la commission vous le voyez être
assez réservés monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole sur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs sur le
sénateur j'ai bien entendu votre
proposition
et c'est vrai que christine albanel trt
plusieurs mois à celle ci est donc dans
ces conditions
comme cet amendement s'inspire
directement des travaux menés par
christine albanel le gouvernement aurait
spontanément pu donner un accord
favorable si la commission est le
rapporteur général n'avait pas dans un
exposé assez nuancée indiqué à la fin et
finalement il y était défavorable et
donc pour toutes ces raisons
comprendrait que le gouvernement s'en
remettent à la sagesse de la haute
assemblée bien devant toutes ces niches
le président veut peut-être évoqué les
chenils ou concessions ce qui m'étonne
c'est l'opinion qui exprime le ministre
elle s'en remettre à la sagesse du sénat
très franchement que l'on puisse
concevoir ce type d'amendements et yann
gaillard me pardonnera témoigne bien de
la profonde crise que nous traversons
vraiment cela devient n'importe quoi je
conçois que madame albanel n'a pas
beaucoup d'argent
il suffit de le dire qu'elle n'a pas
d'argent mais de là à imaginer tous ces
subterfuges qui deviennent des
caricatures c'est le prêt à taux zéro
pour les oeuvres d'art mais enfin qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
notre société il a las am tome aiguë
d'une crise profonde
chaque collège souhaite que nous
puissions nous ressaisir
expliquer aux français ce qu'est cette
crise comment nous allons la traversée
et arrêter d'imaginer pour je ne sais
quelle raison pour satisfaire aux
attentes de telle ou telle catégorie
non ça n'est plus possible alors
monsieur le ministre
très franchement si vous vous apprêtiez
à exprimé depuis favorable permet de
vous dire que j'en suis profondément
choqué car il faudrait que vous étiez
pas d'ordre dans le fonctionnement du
gouvernement pour éviter la conception
d'objets si fantasque et si caricaturaux
qu'est ce que cette société qui va
transformer le banquier en guichet pour
vérifier pour distribuer des prêts à
taux zéro il faut se demander si un jour
les banques paieront suffisamment
d'impôts sur les sociétés pour imputer
tous les intérêts auxquels ils ont
renoncé pour permettre ces prêts à taux
zéro hier sur le logement suis sur le
verdissement du logement et maintenant
les oeuvres d'art nous connaissons bien
toutes les optimisations qui peuvent
être pilotés à la suite ce que nous
votons donc j'invite yann gaillard a pas
être complices de ce type de turpitudes
je remercie monsieur gaillard a demandé
la parole d'abb à vous la parole chez un
collègue
merci monsieur le président vous
connaissez l'adverbe ce qui est excessif
est insignifiant
je trouve que les critiques de notre
rapporteur général non sud je suis
pourtant le complice dans une très
intéressante proposition de loi
favorable au marché de l'art et les
critiques de notre président de la
commission des finances me paraissent un
peu légère par rapport à l'approbation
moral de ministre et je me contenterai
de cette approbation moral je ne
pousserai pas
de ces conditions la présidence a
demandé le vote et je retire
l'amendement
je remercie chers collègues je donne la
parole au ministre pour qu'il puisse
expliciter la demande de sagesse savoir
s'ils étaient positives ou négatives
elle s'inspire d'une pratique qui a lieu
aux états en royaume uni en angleterre
vous dites vous a dit turpitudes trouve
que c'est un peu un peu fort pour ceux
qui fonctionnent bien
au royaume uni il y a la même
disposition qui est qui s'applique pour
8000 libre jusqu'à un plafond de 8
minimes donc vous voyez il y a quand
même quelques pays en tout cas celui ci
qui du reste est souvent citée en
exemple pour la conservation du
patrimoine et la mobilisation de la
société civile pour la conservation de
ce patrimoine connaissait les ce que
fait le royaume uni pour favoriser cette
conservation donc je voulais vous citer
cet exemple pour nuancer vos propos je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
l'amendement est retiré nous passons
maintenant à l'article 50 rectifiée
présentée par monsieur césar vous avez
la parole oui monsieur le président
c'est donc l'amendement 50 rectifié je
rectifie afin de stabiliser les bilans
et d'éviter toutes celles de
surimposition artificiel sa recette
supplémentaire
il est donc proposé par cet événement de
donner une base légale aux avances
culture jusqu alors défini dans une
structure administrative
en effet depuis plus dix ans de
négociations entre professions agricoles
l'administration les experts comptables
il a été convenu l'obligation d'escrimé
avant sa culture dans les stocks c'était
en 1983 une définition précise et
exhaustive de ces avances culture à 6000
allons tous points aux produits la
terminologie bénéfices industriels et
commerciaux avaient été établies
or en arrêt du conseil d'état revient
sur cette définition n'est encore les
fermages cette proposition présentée
sous l'égide logique comptable coûterait
très cher à raison de la variation
d'actifs et de la surimposition sans
profit correspondant qui en résulterait
quant aux propositions d'étalement de la
surimposition sur sept ans elle ne règle
rien et non plus n'ont pas décidé dans
sa base et cotisations sociales
je propose donc monsieur le président d'
adopter cet amendement qui correspond
réellement aux avances aux cultures
nécessaire à toutes les productions en
france
merci je vous remercie chers collègues
la parole un thème sur le rapporteur
général vise à préciser la définition
des avances aux cultures qui
comprendrait les frais correspondants
aux semences les frais de main d'oeuvre
et les frais de matériel mais exclurait
les fermages une instruction
administrative définissez jusqu'ici les
éléments à prendre en compte dans le
calcul les avances aux cultures et
retenait la même définition que
l'amendement propose cette définition a
été remise en cause par un arrêt du
conseil d'état qui a inclus les fermages
dans le calcul les avances aux cultures
ce qui conduit à une augmentation de ses
avances et pourrait produire un
ressources significatives d'imposition
pour certains exploitants et donc
l'amendement nous propose simplement de
revenir au droit antérieur ce qui nous
paraît tout à fait acceptable d'autant
plus que gérard césar avait déposé la
même proposition en première partie du
projet de loi de finances pour 2009 la
ministre chargé de l'économie s'était
engagé à proposer une mesure favorable
dans le prochain collectif budgétaire
alors comme elle ne l'a pas fait
j'imagine que le gouvernement
accueillera favorablement cette
proposition du sénateur gérard césar à
laquelle la commission est tout à fait
favorable
il monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les rapporteurs les
sénateurs pardon
monsieur le sénateur gérard césar
le gouvernement partage l'analyse de la
commission qui vient d'être exposé par
philippe marini vous proposez définir
par la loi cette notion d' avance aux
cultures qui n'était précisé que dans
une instruction administrative remise en
cause à la suite de l'arrêt du conseil
d'état du 20 juillet 2007
donc le gouvernement qui a travaillé
avec vous donne un avis favorable à
votre amendement et et je lève le gage
bien je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre nous allons procéder à la
consultation sur 50 rectifier pour qui
est contre et est adopté nous passons
maintenant un autre amendement présenté
par monsieur césar et monsieur nominatif
za parole chers collègues alors le
changeant tout à fait de registre mais
nous restons calmes de la viticulture et
l'agriculture président le ministère de
la culture a homologué par arrêté le
classement des vins de saint-émilion
établie sous l'égide de l'institut
national des appellations d'origine
le 12 décembre 2006 ce classement a été
annulée le 1er juillet 2008 par le
tribunal invite hâtif de bordeaux le
gouvernement fait adopter dans le
courant de l'été et ne voie permettant
de rétablir le classement antérieur
datant de 1996 mais omis de statuer sur
le sort des huit propriétés qui avait
été promu en 2006 or il apparaît que les
orientations viticole se sont conformés
à ces placements pour se prévaloir de la
mention grand cru classé et 1er en tout
cas c'est alors que plus de 18 mois plus
tard
interdiction leur était faite de se
prévaloir d'une telle mention les chefs
de préjudices qu'ils peuvent être
établis d'après des pièces disponibles
sur les suivants les différentes
propriétés ont réalisé des dix membres
se hisser au rang de grand cru classé de
premier rang classer ces enregistrements
s'avère avoir été réalisée en plus
pour un montant total de 10 millions
d'euros la valeur d'une bouteilles de
grands crus classés par rapport à une
bouteille de grand cru et et 30%
supérieure ens les acheteurs des
millésimes 2006 ont payé pour un grand
cru classé qui s'avère ne pas l'être
il demande donc aujourd'hui
remboursement des sommes dues et indus
la production globale est de 5000
bouteilles par millésime
ce qui pour un prix théorique de 25
euros l'unité représente un préjudice de
plus de 4 millions d'euros frais
d'organisation faire disparaître toute
mention de vente où placer sur les
bouteilles retirez les mouches ont
enlevé l'étiquette à la vapeur
destruction des cartons et caisse bois
et autres affichages réimpression des
emballages dénommé toute mention de
remplacer ray 1 bouteille âgées
bouteille montant estimé ce jour mais
qui devrait significatif pour environ
5000 bouteilles par millésime perte de
notoriété d'image temps pour les vitres
concerné que pour l'ensemble des crus de
saint-émilion en raison de la tempête
médiatique qui a dévalorisé l'image du
cru cette situation inédite doit être
rectifié pour l'exploitation car ils ont
réalisé d'importants efforts tant au
point de vue financier que qualitatif
l'annulation non définitive l'arrêté
ruine ses efforts mais portent surtout
atteinte à l'économie d'une région est à
l'image des vins français à l'étranger
il est donc important d'élargir
dispositif instauré par la loi de
médiation de l'économie en permettant
aussi aux huit chats tourne vraiment à
ces grands crus classés ou premier grand
cru classé utiliser ces nations à des
fins commerciales dans la tare de
nouveaux placements
je vous remercie je vous remercie
monsieur césar il y à un deuxième
amendement qui est identique chez
dominique est identique mais pardon il
est à peu près 10 rédiger un peu
différemment mais avoue adorer la
réponse du ministre sur l'amendement
très bien non mais c'était pour éviter
alors à vis de ces temps
non monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
la question est délicate le ministre
d'agriculture a homologué par arrêté le
classement des vins de saint-émilion le
12 décembre 2006 le classement a été
annulée le 1er juillet 2008
celui ci toute votre attention mes chers
collègues par le tribunal administratif
de bordeaux lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de modernisation de l'économie
le sénat a adopté un amendement présenté
par le gouvernement afin de rétablir le
classement antérieur datant de 1996 soit
ici d'autres attentions
mes chers collègues que la question est
vraiment importante le sang a révélé
vraiment significative et elle est
culturelle culturel je me permets de le
souligner n'est ce pas
alors donc le sénat a adopté un
amendement présenté par le gouvernement
afin de rétablir le classement antérieur
que la tête 96 en revanche il n'a pas
traité le cas des huit propriétés qui
avait été premier en 2006 et qui se
retrouvent en l'état déclassés et les
deux amendements comporte une
disposition identique
il vise à être à élargir le dispositif
instauré par la bonne organisation de
l'économie en permettant à ces huit
châteaux nouvellement classés grands
crus classés ou premier grand cru classé
d'utiliser ces mentions à des fins
commerciales dans l'atteinte d'un
nouveau classement pour les vins issus
des récoltes 2006 à 2009
alors mes chers collègues on appelle le
législateur à prendre des décisions
essentielles qu'il aurait fallu prendre
de façon plus documentée car si l'on
n'avait voulu monsieur le président de
travailler correctement
pardonnez moi de vous le dire il aurait
fallu suspendre et se rendre compte
se rendre compte c'est à dire nous
apporter les éléments nécessaires pour
apprécier puisque on demande aux
législateurs de confirmer un classement
comment le faire sans dégustation n'est
ce pas sans dégustation
bon alors ce n'est peut-être pas
strictement conforme aux usages et je
pense que malgré ce regret nous pouvons
faire confiance aux excellent
connaisseur spécialement notre collègue
gérard césar qui siège dans la haute
assemblée
ceci étant dit il y a deux versions
il y à une version qui est le pur césar
et il y à une version dominati la
version la première exonère les teints
de responsabilité dans le cadre de toute
demande de réparation de préjudices
subis et maintenant des exploitations
viticoles concernés et la seconde
version
elle propose de relever le tarif du
droit de circulation sur les vins afin
de faire face un dédommagement éventuel
et propriétés concernées
donc on comprendra que par prudence la
commission des finances préfère le pur
césar voilà
bien je vous signale que sur le
l'amendement ces armes se domine à
thiais et co signataire et co signataire
de l'amendement que vous avez évoqué la
parole et à monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur césar l'explication
de du rapporteur général est
parfaitement en ligne avec celle à
laquelle je vais me livrer devant vous
cet amendement que vous proposez doit
permettre qu'ils ont grand cru classé et
premiers grands crus classés par les
châteaux qui ont été promus en 2006 et
qu'ils ne peuvent plus les utiliser du
fait de l'annulation par le tribunal de
bordeaux de l'arrêté du 12 décembre 2006
qui avait homologué le classement des
saint-émilion grand cru
au travers de cet amendement vous
souhaitez réparer une situation qui
n'est pas satisfaisante pour un certain
nombre de châteaux le gouvernement un
partage votre souci car cette mesure
permettrait de limiter les conséquences
économiques pour les châteaux qui ont
été promus en 2006 qui était dans
l'obligation de modifier la présentation
de leurs vins du fait de la décision du
tribunal administratif de bordeaux qui
est cette décision est intervenue
tardivement du reste 1er juillet 2008
c'est à dire après la mise en bouteille
des 20 des récoltes 2006 2007 je pense
que cela n'a pas affecté la qualité de
ceux-ci en tout cas dans la bouteille
il faudrait du reste que nous puissions
le constater et je me rallie à la
suggestion qui a été fait par le
rapporteur général dans ce domaine pour
toutes ces raisons le gouvernement tout
en attirant l'attention sur la sécurité
juridique de la maman dans notre
collectif et qui pourrait apparaître
comme un cavalier
nous verrons bien mais je voulais quand
même attirer votre attention sur ce
risque concernant votre amendement pour
autant le gouverneur
on y est favorable et mais il préfère
lui aussi votre amendement qui a du
reste été cosignée par votre collègue
philippe dominati par rapport à aux
siens qui propose d'augmenter le tarif
du droit de circulation du vin dans le
but créer un fonds destiné à indemniser
les entreprises je crois qu'il ne faut
pas aller aussi loin dans la mesure où
nous sommes dans le court deux décisions
de justice
elle doit passer cette décision en appel
très prochainement donc je crois qu'il
ne faut pas anticiper sur cette décision
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaiterais plutôt que vous retiriez
votre amendement sur le sénateur
dominati au profit de l'amendement que
vous avez du res cosigné avec le
sénateur gérard césar
je vous remercie une seule miss monsieur
dominati vous maintenez votre amendement
ou voudront tirer
je voulais vous préciser monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre que mon
amendement effectivement pour ma part je
préfère évidemment l'amendement que j'ai
cosigné avec monsieur césar et je
rejoins en cela votre jugement elle
celui de rapporteur général mais vous
parlez de la sécurité juridique et donc
il fallait un dispositif financier et
c'était la raison pour laquelle je
présentais un second un moment à partir
du moment où effectivement l'amendement
de monsieur césar que j'ai cosigné
apporte toutes les garanties pour
stopper une absurdité économique parce
qu'en réalité c'était faire c'est une
absurdité économique et si elle continue
ça coûtera encore plus cher à l'état
donc c'est pour cela qu'il vaut mieux
faire en sorte qu'on arrête les frais
pour l'état dès maintenant
par contre si nous n'avions si l'état
n'arrivait pas à arrêter maintenant le
dol concernant ces exploitations
viticole il est évident qu'il aurait
fallu avoir une garantie ou en tout cas
des fonds supplémentaires provisionnés
pour l'état pour le substitut et donc à
partir du moment où la sécurité
juridique est garanti j'aurais tire bien
volontiers mon amendement je vous
remercie donc nous allons procéder au
vote sur l'amendement 56 présentée par
monsieur césar et dominati ceux qui sont
david adopté vais là bas pour contre il
est adopté
monsieur césar vous avez noté que le
rapporteur général et le ministre vous
en demandez de constater in vivo dans
les prochains jours la qualité 2-2 se
séparent vague de ce vin a donc tous les
présents bon je vous transmettrai je
demanderai au service de la séance de
vous transmettre la liste de toutes les
personnes qui ont participé et qui était
présent je les connais monsieur le
président ce sont tous les mêmes qui
sont là depuis hier soir à quelque chose
près alors je les connais leur tournée
générale saint-émilion à la buvette à la
l'issue de notre réunion de ce matin
remercie chose à bien nous baissons
après verticale à la main en sang
présidée par monsieur bizet monsieur
jean bizet merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
cet amendement a pour objet d'éviter
l'application des dispositions de
l'article 700 20 du code général des
impôts aux cessions de navires de pêche
maritime
cette position de l'administration rend
toute cession de navires réalisés au
cours des dix dernières années
quel délai de reprise de
l'administration fiscale en matière de
droits d'enregistrement potentiellement
imposable aux droits d'enregistrement
contrairement aux pratiques antérieures
la position de l'administration fiscale
dans la conjoncture financière difficile
que traversent les amendes les armements
à la pêche ne pourra qu'aggraver cette
situation et beaucoup d'entre eux
n'auront même pas
les moyens de s'acquitter de ses droits
d'enregistrement je remercie cher
collègue monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le rapporteur général votre
avis s'il vous plaît la commission a le
sentiment que cet amendement il reste
sans doute dans le sens de plus de
sécurité juridique mais la commission
souhaiterait que le gouvernement puisse
exprimer son avis et se conformera cet
avis est au demeurant nous nous sommes
interrogés sur le chiffrage
l'écart entre le droit proportionnel et
le droit fixe
nous ne savons pas très bien à combien
cela peut nous conduire
ceci dit tout dépend aussi de la bonne
marche de la profession est dans la
période actuelle il serait sans doute
souhaitable de suivre le sens de la
proposition bon condition que cela
apparaisse juridiquement et
budgétairement possible merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jean bizet par
votre amendement vous souhaitez que les
cessions de navires de pêche artisanale
soit enregistrée au doigt droit fixe de
125 euros mais vous indiquer que le
gouvernement partage votre souci de
favoriser la reprise de ce type
d'activité j'ajoute que cet amendement
s'il est adopté permettra de régler de
nombreux contentieux en cours pour ça
que je donne mon accord à cet amendement
je vous indiquer que la loi de
modernisation de l'économie ayant créé
les articles 7 132 bis ses terres la
mesure dont nous discutons et créer à
l'article
732 quater du code général des impôts
pour répondre à monsieur le rapporteur
général je le voulais lui indiquer un
ordre de grandeur qui serais tu
maximum entre 2 et 3 millions d'euros
maxime vous lever le gage
oui monsieur précisé monsieur le
ministre monsieur godefroy souhaité
intervenir
l'outil de l'éducation de ses miss je
voudrais dire que je suis très heureux
de la position devient 2.2 monsieur le
ministre je ne vais pas longer le propos
j'avais préparé une aide à mon collègue
jean bizet mais comme vous avez émis un
avis favorable je voulais dire que pour
ce qui me concerne ce qu'il concerne
nous voterons cette cet amendement car
ça concerne véritablement la survie de
la pêche dans nos départements
il est certain et nous avons des cas
actuellement il est certain que les
armateurs devant une telle situation ne
pourront plus continuer à exploiter d'un
navire est le navire c'est exactement
comme le cheptel pour les agriculteurs
donc je crois qu'il est tout à fait
normal qu'ils soient traités de la même
façon et si chers collègues sur le sens
inquiets pour qui est contre unanimité
il est adopté nous passons à l'article
42 bis
là nous avons deux amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune
le premier présenté par le rapporteur
général si demain elle présentait alors
il ne s'agit guère que d'un amendement
de suppression n'est ce pas d'un article
introduit à l'assemblée nationale qui
vient préciser la possibilité pour les
investisseurs particuliers de déduire de
leurs revenus fonciers les charges
financières supportées dans la
construction et la réparation
d'immeubles destinés au logement social
et qui prévoit une application
rétroactive à compter de l'imposition
des revenus de 2006 afin d'inclure les
opérations d'investissement déjà engagés
nous avons considéré que la
rétroactivité de l'article et est
inhabituel puisqu'elle remonte jusqu'aux
revenus de 2006
et conduire est à récompenser entre
guillemets des contribuables qui
n'auraient pas forcément pris leurs
décisions d'investissement en fonction
de cet avantage particulier je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur
c'est monsieur badré qui présente la
maman 97 rectifier vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bien sûr
cet amendement que je présente un
instant tombera si l'amendement de la
commune de notre commission est votée ce
que je souhaite bien sûr mais il met
l'occasion il me donne l'occasion de
saluer ici l'engagement de notre
collègue jean marie vanlerenberghe
l'auteur de cet amendement en faveur du
logement social et de son développement
et de soutien au logement social qui
soit compatible avec l'équilibré des
finances locales
cet amendement par cet amendement jean
marie vanlerenberghe souligne que
l'acquisition par des investisseurs
privés de la nue propriété de logements
dont il compile confie l'usufruit pour
10 à 20 ans un bailleur social se
développe
l'acquéreur ne paie donc une fraction du
prix du logement dont ils récupèrent la
pleine propriété au palais au terme de
la période d'usufruit l'amendement a
pour objet d'élargir la liste des
bailleurs sociaux susceptibles d'être
juge fruitiers de ce type de logement au
cem et aux organismes concourant aux
objectifs de la politique d aide au
logement des tels qu'ils sont définis à
l'article l 365 2 du code de la
construction et de l'habitation
si celle collègues je vais demander
l'avis du gouvernement enfin pardon
l'avis de la commission sur le deuxième
amendement fruit locatif social
c'est une méthode d'une simplicité
extrême
le particulier investisseur
nu-propriétaire bénéficier d'un mode
d'accession à la propriété très
avantageux en effet le jeu free locative
sociale consiste en un démembrement
temporaire du droit de propriété d'un
côté la nue propriété qui appartient des
investisseurs qui financent la
construction
d'autre part l'usufruit qui est acquis
par un bailleur social lequel perçoit
l'intégralité des loyers assure
l'entretien de l'immeuble
la convention est établi pour une durée
minimale de 15
en terme des 15 ans l'investisseur privé
récupère la propriété entière du bien
l'intérêt de l'opération pour
l'investisseur c'est d'acquérir une
nue-propriété d'un appartement etc une
mise de fonds réduits de l'ordre de 50 à
60 % la valeur réelle du bien en
fonction de la convention conclue
question pouvant être de savoir quelle
est la consistance de ce qu'il récupère
au bout de 15 ans est ce que ça vaut la
commission a vous l'avez constaté
proposé la suppression l'article 42 bis
au motif que cela tend à créer une
nouvelle niche dont l'effet incitatif
pas ré mineur au regard du gain escompté
au terme inconscient d'usufruit et j'ai
insisté et quelques instants sur
l'application rétroactive aux revenus de
2006 présente amendement étant au
contraire le champ d'application de
l'article 42 bis et va donc à l'opposé
des préoccupations qui ont été émises
par la commission et c'est pourquoi
celle ci en souhaite le retrait je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur min sur ces deux amendements
votre avis alors monsieur le président
sur l'amendement de suppression
présentés par monsieur marini
je ne suis pas en accord avec lui bien
que je comprenne son souci de limiter la
création de niches mais il faut aller au
delà de ceux ci de quoi s'agit-il
en fait il s'agit de favoriser le
logement social
on ne veut pas d'un côté avoir une
priorité compte tenu des besoins avérés
dans ce domaine et ne pas regarder de
près ce que propose sept mesures qui
permettraient de qui est en conformité
avec la loi dite sru et qui a déjà fait
l'objet du reste de la construction de
3000 logements 3000 logements
monsieur le rapporteur général de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale gilles carez propose et a fait
adopter par l'assemblée nationale des
intérêts déductibles donc l'autorisation
pour les nus-propriétaires de déduire
les intérêts d'emprunts contractés en
vue d'acquérir des logements dont
l'usufruit est temporairement détenu par
un organismes d'habitations à loyer
modéré
cette quelque chose qui va favoriser
encore cette mesure alors j'y serais
tout à fait favorable mais je suis
sensible à l'argumentation du rapporteur
général concernant les modalités
d'entrée en vigueur modalités d'entrée
en vigueur puisque les intérêts seraient
déductibles rétroactivement depuis 2006
on peut on peut discuter de cette
rétroactivité et la commission mixte
paritaire a sûrement à en débattre
c'est pour ça que je m'en remets à la
sagesse de l'assemblée
sur ce point
mais je donne aussi mon avis favorable à
l'extension aux cem dans proposé par
l'amendement 97
dès lors qu'on est d'accord sur
l'économie d'ensemble tels que
l'assemblée nationale l'a adopté il
s'agira maintenant de discuter en cmp de
cette mesure qui me semble être une
bonne mesure même si on peut en discuter
les modalités d'application et la
philosophie générale de la création de
niches supplémentaires
le rapporteur général de persister dans
la suppression mais dans une suppression
qui ne soit pas complètement négative
c'est-à-dire une suppression qui laisse
l'article ouvert et permet à la cmp de
rédiger un texte qui correspondent à nos
préoccupations et à celle du
gouvernement en particulier de revenir
sur la rétroactivité peut-être de
rectifier d'autres éléments de la
rédaction du dispositif
donc je vous convie à supprimer non pas
pour abolir cette mesure qui peut être
utile dans certains cas de figure mais
pour la contenir de manière plus plus
plus équitable ce à quoi nous devrions
parvenir d'ici demain après midi bien je
vous remercie monsieur à partager la
parole est un monsieur jean pierre
fourcade purification merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur général en milieu urbain
dense
lorsqu'à pas beaucoup de terrains
disponibles pour faire des logements
sociaux
ce système de séparation entre la propre
la nue propriété et l'usufruit permet
effectivement de faire un certain nombre
de logements sociaux et nous l'avons
fait dans certaines communes très
fortement ont peuplé est très dense je
reconnais avec l'important général que
c'est un peu choquant de permettent une
déduction rétroactive des intérêts
et de faire un cadeau supplémentaire des
gens qui se sont même engagés dans ce
type d'opération l'ennui de voter la
suppression c'est qu'on ne pourra pas
adopter l'amendement de monsieur
vanlerenberghe et monsieur van
l'amendement qu'à présenter monsieur
badra est excellent parce qu'il permet
de remettre à égalité les offices et les
sociétés d'économie mixte où les
organismes qui peuvent permettre de
faire cette opération
en conséquence moi il me semble qu'il
faudra de toute manière en cmp arriver à
une solution on peut choisir l'une des
deux mais je voudrais qu'on conserve en
mémoire l'amendement défendu par
monsieur badr est parce que je crois
qu'il vaut mieux si on crée cette
faculté
je crois qu'il vaut mieux l'étendre à
tous ceux qui fabriquent et qui met en
service du logement social
monsieur badri vous souhaitez la parole
oui merci monsieur le président oui
j'allais ajouter après jean pierre
fourcade qu'en tout état de cause s'il
est intéressant de faire un vivier sert
de faire vivre le débat jusqu'à la cmp
comme membre de la commission des
finances je suis évidemment très être
insensible aux arguments qui a développé
le rapporteur général mais mon excellent
collègue jean marie vanlerenberghe ayant
prié de soutenir sa son idée qui me
paraît également intéressante
je demande au rapporteur général de ne
pas m'en vouloir si je ne vote pas
l'amendement de la commission même si au
fond de moi même j'en aurais envie
ne serait-ce à nouveau que par égard
pour mon collègue et pour faire vivre le
débat jusqu'à la cmp de demain après
midi
voilà vous venez de suivre l'examen du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
pour 2008 a suite de l'examen du texte
cet après midi à 16h30 très bonne
journée à tous